besides neural anatomical changes in
flow there are neural chemical changes
right the brain produces a giant cascade
of neural chemistry you get
norepinephrine dopamine
Amanda mine serotonin and endorphins all
five of these are performance enhancing
neuro chemicals right so they make you
faster stronger quicker and they do the
same thing with your brain the front end
of a flow state you take in more
information process it more deeply
meaning you process it using more parts
of your brain you process it more
quickly there's some debate about this
but it does appear that you process it
more quickly
this is norepinephrine and dopamine so
when people enter a flow state they talk
about feeling like their senses are
incredibly heightened this is the
performance-enhancing aspect of
norepinephrine and dopamine where these
chemicals really come in handy is how
they affect motivation creativity and
learning
we'll start with motivation besides
being performance-enhancing chemicals
these are obviously all feel-good drugs
right these five chemicals are the most
potent feel-good drugs the brain can
produce as a result flow is considered
the most addictive state on earth
scientists don't like the word addictive
so they use autotelic when something is
autotelic it is an end in itself what it
means is that once an experience starts
producing flow we will go
extraordinarily far out of our way to
get more of it which is why researchers
now believe flow is the source code of
intrinsic motivation another thing that
those neural chemicals do is they
augment the creative process so
creativity is always recombinant or it's
the product novel information bumping
into old thoughts to create something
startling new so if you want to amplify
creativity you want to amplify every
aspect of that process again the neuro
chemicals help so on the front end of
the flow state when you get
norepinephrine and dopamine they're
tightening focus so you are taking in
more information per second so you're
boosting that part of the creative
process norepinephrine and dopamine do
something else in the brain which is
they lower signal-to-noise ratios so you
detect more patterns they jack up
pattern recognition so our ability to
link ideas together is also enhanced
we're taking in more information we can
link it
together Amanda mine which is another
chemical that shows up and flow doesn't
just promote pattern recognition
promotes lateral thinking so pattern
recognition is more more or less the
linking of familiar ideas together
lateral thinking is the linking of very
disparate ideas together right so more
information per second all kinds of
pattern recognition lateral thinking all
of it surrounds the creative process and
amplifies all of it which is why for
example studies run by my organization
the flow Genome Project we found
creativity is increased 500 to 700
percent to give you another example in a
recent Australian study that took 42
people give them a very tricky brain
teaser to solve the climate needs very
creative problem-solving
nobody could solve the problem they
induce flow artificially using
transcranial magnetic stimulation to
basically knock out the prefrontal
cortex they induced artificial transient
hypofrontality technically as a result
23 people solve the problem in record
time so massively amplified motivation
massively amplified creativity the last
thing Flo does it's really important is
it jacks up learning so a quick
shorthand for how learning works is the
more neural chemicals that show up
during experience the better chance that
experience has a movement with
short-term holding into long-term
storage right neuro chemicals among
their many other functions one of them
is to tag experiences big neon sign
saying really important save for later
because flow is this giant neural
chemical dump it massively amplifies
learning so in studies run by DARPA and
researchers it had been advanced brain
monitoring California when they
introduced flow artificially this time
kind of using neurofeedback in soldiers
marksmen to be exact
they found that soldiers in flow learn
to shoot 230 percent faster than normal
when they redid this study using novice
marksmen they did it with riflemen and
archers what they discovered is that the
period of time it takes to train a
novice Archer or novice marksman up to
the expert level when they're in flow
can be cut in half so Malcolm Gladwell's
famous 10,000 hours to mastery what the
research shows is that flow cuts it in
half
you